[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit keiner
silbe richter und marietta slomka
guten abend an diesem 23 august bei
historikern klappt da sofort das
geschichtsbuch auf am 23
august 1939 wurde der hitler stalin pakt
unterzeichnet in dem die beiden
diktatoren einen teil ihrer
nachbarschaft unter anderem polen und
das baltikum unter sich aufteilten und
wäre die erinnerung daran normalerweise
natürlich keinen einstieg in eine
aktuelle nachrichtensendung aber es
lohnt sich zur kenntnis zu nehmen dass
das russische außenministerium diesen
jahrestag heute auf social media
zelebriert geschichts umdeutung
inklusive eine heroisierung der
vergangenheit die auch eine wurzel
heutigen übels ist in der ukraine
jedenfalls die morgen ihren
unabhängigkeitstag begeht herrscht
größte anspannung war mit schweren
russischen angriffen gerechnet wird und
noch eine angst treibt die ukraine um
das der westen nicht durchhält florian
neumann berichtet
vielleicht helfen ja auch solche bilder
gegen das vergessen ein kulturzentrum in
brüssel ein verein von ukrainern in
belgien und eine erkenntnis das
interesse am krieg in ihrer heimat lässt
nach also stellen sie bilder ausgemalt
von geflüchteten aus der ukraine
das ist ein bild des stadtzentrums von
harke eine der größten und schönsten
städte der ukraine leider auch wegen der
nähe zu russland an der meist
bombardierten nur findet das eben nicht
mehr in den nachrichten statt
wie anders im frühling als beinahe jedes
bauwerk in den farben der ukraine
angestrahlt wurde als dem großen schock
in europa die noch größere
hilfsbereitschaft folgte
sechs monate nach seinem beginn ist
dieser krieg nur noch eine geschichte
von vielen europa mit der frage
ausgelastet ob es genügend gas für den
winter bekommt und der nato
generalsekretär im zdf interview damit
beschäftigt den kurs gegenüber russland
zu verteidigen moral gegen müdigkeit
winter kommt und der winter wird hart
sein ja wir werden einen preis bezahlen
aber der preis den wir zahlen kann in
geld gemessen werden der preis den die
ukraine zahlen wird in leben gemessen
leben die jeden tag verloren gehen als
lost everyday kann man sich an das
grauen gewöhnen so lange es weit weg ist
dass der westen müde wird zeigt sich an
vielen stellen an pipelines die mancher
gern öffnen würde oder an hilfen ob
finanziell oder militärisch die nach
beobachtungen von wissenschaftlern
stoppen
in deutschland ist ja jede menge
bewegung wenn es darum geht kriegsfolgen
abzupuffern aber es geht eben immer um
inländische bedürfnisse energiepaket
tank rabatte rettung von
energieunternehmen wenn man nur einen
kleinen teil an die ukraine weitergeben
würde dieses neue mobilisierten geldes
dann wäre schon viel geholfen hat tut
europa genug auch der
nato-generalsekretär ist nicht zufrieden
er ist vor ein paar tagen haben die usa
weitere militärhilfe angekündigt über
zusätzliche 800 millionen us dollar ich
erwarte auch von den europäischen
verbündeten dass sie hier voranschreiten
und dann tut sich an diesem tag doch
noch etwas ein video gipfel zur krim der
deutsche kanzler zugeschaltet aus kanada
mit einer zusage wir werden die ukraine
finanziell unterstützen und wir werden
weiterhin waffen liefert 500 millionen
euro verspricht er etwa für
flugabwehrsysteme lieferungen maßgeblich
im kommenden jahr ob dann noch gekämpft
wird nicht einmal stoltenberg wagt eine
prognose
wir haben die russische invasion sehr
genau vorhersagen können schon im
letzten herbst aber wie der krieg
verlaufen wird ist unvorhersehbar
als der krieg begann rechneten viele mit
einem schnellen sieg russlands sechs
monate später kämpfen sie immer noch die
ukraine auch gegen das vergessen
hebestreit ist unser reporter in der
ukraine in kiew einer diese ankündigung
von olaf scholz neue waffenlieferungen
das wird man wahrscheinlich gerade heute
am vorabend des nationalfeiertags der
ukraine gerne hören oder
davon würde ich mal ausgehen heute sie
auch tag der nationalfahne in der
ukraine und präsident selensky hat sich
heute morgen höchstpersönlich gehisst
und hat versprochen dass diese fahne
auch über den besetzten gebieten bald
wieder hängen werde besetzte gebiete das
sind etwa 20 prozent der ukrainischen
landesfläche und im
verteidigungsministerium haben sie uns
heute gesagt ja man hat auf jeden fall
vor dass alles wieder zu befreien und so
eine befreiung geht natürlich nicht ohne
unterstützung aus dem westen da kommt
das deutsche angebot sicherlich ganz
recht das ganze hat aber auch eine
psychologische komponente hier rund um
tiere von dem rest des landes ist man
sehr nervös weil man sorge hat vom
russischen angriffen rund um diesem
nationalfeiertag die amerikanische
botschaft hat schon gesagt liebe
landsleute verlasst bitte die ukraine
mit so etwas ist die botschaft der
amerikaner immer sehr schnell andere
botschaften haben dann nicht nachgezogen
auch die deutschen nicht wollen wir mal
hoffen dass es in der nacht und in den
nächsten tagen hier ruhig bleibt sprach
das eben schon angehört sich heute auch
noch mal einer rede an das volk gewendet
und er hat auch ansprüche auf die
rückeroberung der krim erhoben und das
ganz deutlich gesagt
ja das wort rückeroberung würde ich
ihnen dem zusammenhang sehr vorsichtig
benutzen der sprach vom countdown der
die okkupation
es gab ja in den letzten wochen einige
militärische sehr schmerzhafte
nadelstiche gegenüber den russischen
truppen an sich gilt aber eine
militärische rückeroberung der krim
allgemein als ding der unmöglichkeit
bleibt also der verhandlungsweg und da
hat er heute auch unterstützung vom
türkischen präsidenten erdogan erhalten
also einen flug eingerahmten danke dir
für die einschätzung nach kiew
und dazu gibt es nachher heute schon ein
update noch ein interview mit dem
scheidenden botschafter andrej melik
die ankündigung für weitere waffen zu
liefern machte olaf scholz wie gesagt in
kanada er uns an gastgeber justin trio
sicherten der ukraine gemeinsam ihre
solidarität zum dass der deutsche
kanzler doch der deutsche
wirtschaftsminister gleich drei tage
lang kanada besuchen ist ja auch eine
folge des krieges
die in der die partnerschaft mit
russland ist zerschlagen kann er da ein
attraktiver neuer partner gerade auch im
bereich grüner energie passend dazu sind
stolz und harbeck von toronto nach
neufundland und labrador geflogen und
dort soeben gelandet dieser raum
kanadischen provinz verdankt die welt ja
bereits zwei beliebte hunderassen
künftig soll dort eine grüne
wasserstoffproduktion im großen stil
entstehen
kanada und deutschland wollen dazu
gleich einen abkommen unterzeichnen was
das eigentlich ist grüner wasserstoff
erklärt christian kusch
wasserstoff ein farbloses und
geruchloses element soll unsere
energieversorgung unabhängiger machen
und klimafreundlicher aber wie genau
wasserstoff atome begegnen uns fast
überall aber nie allein sondern immer
gebunden am häufigsten in form von
wasser also in verbindung mit sauerstoff
um den wasserstoff abzutrennen ist das
gebräuchlichste verfahren die sogenannte
elektrolyse dabei wird mit hilfe von
strom das wasser zerlegt in wasserstoff
und sauerstoff
die elektrische energie wird also in
chemische energie umgewandelt und im
wasserstoff gespeichert die so
gespeicherte energie kann dann etwa in
einer brennstoffzelle durch zusatz von
sauerstoff wieder freigesetzt werden und
genutzt
wasserstoff ist also keine energiequelle
die erdöl erdgas wind wasser oder
sonnenlicht sondern ein energieträger
also ein speicher der aufgewendete strom
zur herstellung von wasserstoff soll
nicht mit hilfe von gas oder kohle
hergestellt werden sondern
klimafreundlich erneuerbar das ergebnis
grüner wasserstoff so werden wir
unabhängiger und kommen beim klimaschutz
voran
um gewonnene wasserstoff energie zu
speichern und zu transportieren muss
diese wieder gebunden werden mit
kohlendioxid oder stickstoff der
gebundene wasser stoffe den spitzel
tanks gelagert aus diesem prozess heraus
können auf synthetisch hergestellte
kraftstoffe entstehen um etwa normalen
diesel zu ersetzen
nachteile mit jedem umwandlungsprozess
sind die energieeffizienz der
strombedarf ist hoch und viele
wasserstoff technologien sind noch nicht
marktreif bisher wasserstoff zu erzeugen
und dann zu nutzen ist bislang zu teuer
ist also nicht wirtschaftlich fossile
energien waren bislang einfach günstiger
das möchten die bundesregierung und die
eu kommission bis 2030 ändern ein
wasserstoff markt mit entsprechender
infrastruktur soll ausgebaut werden
dieser soll die industrie den
schwerlastverkehr und teile des
wärmemarktes mit wasserstoffversorgung
ein problem gilt es dabei im auge zu
behalten die wasserstoff systeme müssten
immer streng überwacht werden denn
wasserstoff ist in seiner reinform
hochentzündlich
so ist jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von
kai selbe richter da schauen wir auf den
kampf gegen geldwäsche der in
deutschland als wenig effektiv gilt
deshalb plant finanzminister lindner
einen kurswechsel laut dem spiegel will
er eine neue bundesbehörde schaffen mit
einem finanz kriminalamt das
eigenständig fanden und ermitteln darf
eine zweite säule soll
verdachtsmeldungen besser filtern eine
dritte für eine bessere aufsicht sorgen
zum beispiel über die immobilien oder
glücksspielbranche wo besonders viel
schwarzgeld im umlauf ist im streit über
die besteuerung von dienstwagen haben
die grünen einen kompromiss
vorgeschlagen demnach könnten die autos
weiterhin steuerlich abgesetzt werden
allerdings würde dabei der co2 ausstoß
stärker berücksichtigt fraktionschefin
dröge sagte dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland bislang würden beim
sogenannten dienstwagen privileg vor
allem oberklasse wagen mit hohem
spritverbrauch gefördert das müsse sich
ändern
vom koalitionspartner spd kommt
unterstützung die automobilindustrie
kritisiert die reformpläne
nach dem fischsterben in der oder wurden
in polen mehr als 280 ungenehmigte
abwasserkanäle entdeckt man prüfe
derzeit von wo aus sie gelegt wurden und
von wem so die wasserbehörde nach
schätzungen des instituts für
binnenfischerei starben bis zu 50
prozent der oder fische als möglicher
grund gilt die massive ausbreitung
giftige algen die hintergründe sind aber
noch unklar
kanzlerin angela merkel wird mit dem
friedenspreis der unesco geehrt wegen
ihres einsatzes in der flüchtlingskrise
2015 jury präsident und
friedensnobelpreisträger denn es muss
wege sagte ihre mutige entscheidung mehr
als 1,2 millionen geflüchtete
aufzunehmen sei eine lektion die sie der
geschichte hinterlassen wann der preis
an merkel übergeben wird steht noch
nicht fest
wie ein mahnmal erinnert es an die
explosionskatastrophe von beirut im
hafen der libanesischen hauptstadt ist
der nordteil des riesigen getreidesilos
komplett eingestürzt wochenlang hatte es
darin gebrannt der getreidespeicher war
bei dem unglück vor zwei jahren
beschädigt worden damals waren tausende
tonnen ungesichertes ammoniumnitrat
explodiert mehr als 200 menschen starben
staatliche untersuchungen zur
katastrophe wurden immer wieder
ausgesetzt
am horn von afrika herrscht die
schlimmste dürre seit 40 jahren deshalb
schlägt die unicef alarm mehr als 16
millionen menschen seien dort ohne
zuverlässigen zugang zu sauberem wasser
ähnlich dramatisch sei es in der sahel
zone und es fehlt nicht nur an wasser
laut uno haben allein in ostafrika fast
90 millionen menschen nicht genug zu
essen darunter viele kinder
auch in europa herrscht dürre und auch
wenn auf unserem wohlhabenden kontinent
die auswirkungen nicht entweder
afrikanischen sahelzone vergleichbar
sind die ausmaße sind auch bei uns doch
grade
experten der eu gehen in ihrem aktuellen
bericht davon aus dass fast die hälfte
europas dürre bedroht ist und auf rund
17 prozent der fläche sei der zustand
bereits alarmierend wie man sieht ist
auch deutschland davon betroffen
vor diesem hintergrund zog der
bauernverband heute eine vorläufige
erntebilanz die und dass die natur der
sache gemischt ausfällt nicht alle sind
gleichermaßen betroffen
abhängig davon was man anbaut und wo
angebote berichtet
landwirt erich gussen zeigt uns sein
zuckerrüben fällt bei jülich auf den
ersten blick sieht es doch recht grün
aus das problem liegt tiefer
zumal sich die züricher kümmern tiefes
loch gemacht unten ist alles nur
trockener boden und oben ist eine kleine
feuchte schicht
das ist der willigen am freitag gefallen
war aber das
hält nur von udes bis gleich die blätter
der zuckerrüben teils abgestorben und
die knollen viel zu klein noch
kläglicher sieht es bei den kartoffeln
aus gleich nebendran die pflanzen zum
großen teil vertrocknet und tod bei
seinen sogenannten herbst kulturen
rechnet erich gussen mit ernteeinbußen
bis zu 50 prozent und er hat noch glück
dank eines guten des bodens gute böden
können was auch speicherung und das ist
dann gerade in solchen jahren macht sich
das bemerkbar
aber jetzt zum nach hinten raus zu den
herz kulturen ist jetzt bei uns auch
kein wasser mehr da und ist auch leider
keine in sicht für die nächsten tage
seine winterweizenernte hat der landwirt
aus jülich schon eingefahren die war
sogar ein bisschen besser als im letzten
jahr dank eines regen reichen winters
mit seinen erträgen liegt erich gussen
ziemlich genau im bundesweiten
durchschnitt doch im vergleich zu den
jahren 2014 bis 21 liegt der ertrag 8
prozent unter dem durchschnitt die
preise für verbraucher werden wohl
steigen so der deutsche bauernverband
wir haben auf der einen seite nämlich
niedrige erträge und auf der anderen
seite eine kostenexplosion
düngemittelpreise vervierfacht
energiekosten verdoppelt
futtermittelkosten erhöht und um
überhaupt weiter wirtschaften zu können
brauchen wir als bauern höhere preise
die erntebilanz fällt regional sehr
unterschiedlich aus während im
nordwesten und am alpenrand dem pflanzen
oftmals ausreichend wasser zur verfügung
steht herrscht in der mitte deutschlands
teils extreme dürre und auf wetter
extreme werden sich die landwirte in
zukunft wohl einstellen müssen der
klimawandel trifft uns bauern ins mark
und wir arbeiten seit jahren daran
diesem entgegentreten zu können wagen
uns auch ein neue kulturen über
spielsweise kichererbsen heran die hitze
mögen neue andere kulturpflanzen um sich
den veränderten klimabedingungen
anzupassen
landwirt erich gussen ist da skeptisch
nützt mir nichts wenn ich jetzt hier
eine form von irgendwo weizenanbau der
erst mal im ertrag schlecht ist
der aber markt nicht gefragt ist also
ich muss ja irgendwo was erlösen weil
ich muss ja letztendlich nachher
gewinn erwirtschaften wenn ich meine
familie ernähren können
die aussichten für erich gussen
kartoffeln bleiben düster im laufe der
woche soll es hier in jülich wieder über
30 grad warm werden regen ist nicht
angesagt
ein 16 jähriger stirbt getroffen von
fünf polizeikugeln anfang des monats war
das geschehen in einer
jugendhilfeeinrichtung in dortmund der
gewaltsame tod des minderjährigen aus
dem senegal hat hohe wellen geschlagen
was war da los warum ist der
polizeieinsatz dort so eskaliert
eigentlich waren die beamten gerufen
wurden weil der junge offenbar im
begriff war sich selbst etwas anzutun
es gibt eine ganze reihe fragen zu
diesem einsatz denen auch der
nordrhein-westfälische landtag nach geht
vor dessen hauptausschuss trat heute
innenminister roy inwieweit das zur
aufklärung beiträgt hat thomas münten
beobachtet
sie treffen sich fast jeden tag zum
protest auf dem marktplatz in der
dortmunder nordstadt william donzé
organisiert das ganze eher wild das
aufgeklärt wird was hier passiert ist am
achten august ein 16-jähriger
flüchtlinge aus dem senegal wurde von
der polizei mit fünf schüssen aus einer
maschinenpistole getötet zuvor war mit
einem messer unterwegs hatte angekündigt
sich umzubringen
das nordviertel geprägt von armut und
zuwanderung findet keine ruhe
es ist vor allem die sicherheit sorgen
und auch die sorge über das verhältnis
zwischen bevölkerungen beziehungsweise
sehr junge menschen hier dass sie wenn
sie wenn es mal vorkommen dass mit der
polizei irgendwie zu tun haben dass die
polizei situationen auch vor allem hier
mit einer mit eine ruhige pädagogische
art und weise vielleicht der eskaliert
mindestens fünf streifenwagen mindestens
elf polizisten der junge mann gerade
erst angekommen quasi ohne
deutschkenntnisse
er sei mit dem messer auf sie zugelaufen
haben die polizisten ausgesagt sie
hätten in notwehr gehandelt die body
camps die sie zum einsatz trugen waren
wohl alle nicht eingeschaltet heute
musste landesinnenminister herbert reul
dem landtag dazu rede und antwort stehen
hauptaussage die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt so lange kann man konkret
nichts sagen erstens man muss die fakten
kennen zweites muss man nachdenken
bewerten und dann wären folgerungen
gezogen und das wir zwingen zu sein aber
ich kann noch nicht handeln bevor ich
gar nicht weiß was passiert ist da
könnten die body camps helfen besser als
jede spurensicherung laut gesetz dürfen
sich die beamten aber nicht selbst
aufnehmen es trägt sie dazu bei dass es
vertrauen in die rechtmäßigkeit der
polizeilichen handlungen schwindet denn
man wird sicher sagen die haben schon
grund wenn sie die sich nicht selbst
aufnehmen das hat ein geschmäckle
und ich fürchte das trägt zum
vertrauensverlust in die deutsche
polizei bei
dass in solchen fällen eng benachbarten
polizeibehörden die ermittlungen gegen
die beamten geschossen haben übernehmen
sei ebenfalls unglücklich mein bär es
brauche absolute unabhängigkeit
im moment haben wir in deutschland keine
solche stelle die in der lage wäre
sowohl unabhängig von der polizei oder
dem innenministerium zu sein als auch
selbst zu ermitteln
das aber würden sie sich wünschen in der
dortmunder nordstadt um sich sicherer zu
fühlen
und jetzt noch mal kein server mit
anderen themen und meldungen da kommen
wir noch mal aufs thema energie zurück
bis zum ersten oktober sollen ja die
deutschen gasspeicher zu 85 prozent
gefüllt sein so sieht es eine verordnung
vor die meisten kommen jetzt schon auf
über 80 das hat die bundesnetzagentur
bekannt gegeben das klingt im ersten
moment beruhigend stefanie welt im
zweiten auch noch ja also wir sollten
uns da nicht in falscher sicherheit
wiegen denn selbst hundertprozentig
gefüllte speicher werden uns nicht über
den ganzen winter bringen sie reichen
das klingt ein bisschen ernüchternd
lediglich für acht bis zehn wochen aus
um deutschland ein jahr lang zu
versorgen waren bislang 100 milliarden
kubikmeter erdgas nötig die deutschen
speicher kapazitäten umfassen aber nur
23 milliarden kubikmeter und sollen
eigentlich auch nur die
verbrauchsspitzen abfedern das heißt wir
sind weiterhin auf stetige gas
lieferungen angewiesen deutschland
importiert deutlich weniger gas aus
russland dafür inzwischen sehr viel mehr
aus norwegen belgien und den
niederlanden
hier landet auch flüssiggas also lng aus
den usa an den gas- terminals an dort
wird es für den transport durch
pipelines umgewandelt und nach
deutschland geleitet doch im winter
könnte es eng werden mit den
lieferkapazitäten denn auch andere eu
länder sind auf die einfuhren angewiesen
deshalb muss weiter eingespart werden
auch wenn die industrie bereits in den
letzten monaten weit weniger gas
verbraucht als sonst dafür sorgten schon
die hohen einkaufspreise und wer konnte
stellte die produktion auf andere
energiequellen um aus angst vor der
gasmenge lage die droht nämlich wenn
russland gar kein gas mehr liefert und
die speicher füllstände schneller sinken
denn am ersten oktober der beginn der
heizperiode und dann wird auch wieder
gas aus den speichern benötigt vor allem
wenn der winter streng wird private
haushalte haben bislang noch vorrang für
unternehmen bleibt die energie krise
wohl aber noch länger das existenzielle
thema ebenso wie die in lieferketten
problematik dankeschön stefanie berit
und da gibt es gute nachrichten im
tarifstreit für die norddeutschen
hafenarbeiter gibt es eine einigung
damit sind weitere streiks vom tisch die
die lieferketten weiter belastet hätten
je nach betriebsart steigen die löhne
rückwirkend zum ersten juli um 9,4 bzw
79 im kommenden jahr noch einmal um 4,4
prozent sollte die inflation dann weiter
so hoch sein kann der tarifvertrag
gekündigt und neu verhandelt werden die
steigenden preise machen sich zunehmend
auch auf den sparkonten bemerkbar laut
dem ifo institut sind die ersparnisse
aus corona zeiten schon wieder
aufgezehrt weil auf dem höhepunkt der
pandemie urlaub oder restaurantbesuche
kaum möglich waren hatten die guthaben
bis zum meer 2021 um gut 70 milliarden
euro zugenommen dieses plus sei ende
märz dieses jahres aber schon wieder
abgeschmolzen
und jetzt haben wir noch nie gesehene
aufnahmen gefunkt vom james webb
teleskop zu sehen ist der jupiter gut zu
erkennen sein markenzeichen der berühmte
große rote fleck ein langzeit
wirbelsturm der größer ist als unsere
erde hier aus technischen gründen weiß
dargestellt
außerdem zu sehen leuchtenden
polarlichter und wirbel aus polaren
dunst eine beteiligte astronomen brachte
es so auf den punkt wir hätten nicht
gedacht dass die aufnahmen so gut werden
am anfang der sendung konnten wir das
schon einen blick ins geschichtsbuch auf
den hitler-stalin-pakt
geschichtlich ist auch begründet dass in
polen oder den baltischen staaten das
misstrauen gegenüber russland so viel
größer war als in deutschland und wird
dort auch immer wieder warnungen
gegenüber berlin ausgesprochen würden
durch den russischen überfall auf die
ukraine sieht man sich dort nun
bestätigt und lässt jetzt auch manche
selbstbeschränkungen gegenüber russland
fallen in lettland etwa soll nun ein
berühmtes denkmal aus der sowjetzeit
abgerissen werden warum das ein durchaus
heikles vorabend ist erklärt natürlich
stieg
gigantisch sagt er über der stadt der 80
meter hohe obelisk mit sternen oben
erinnert an den sieg der roten armee
über nazi deutschland seit 1985 in riga
als lettland noch teil der sowjetunion
war nun soll er fallen das gebiet
drumherum weitläufig abgesperrt und
abgesichert die gesellschaft muss dies
verstehen und ruhig bleiben alles wird
in ordnung sein
doch die lettische gesellschaft treibt
die sum denn ein teil der bevölkerung
hat russische wurzeln die gesellschaft
gespalten viele letten wiederum feiern
seit mai die entscheidung dass das
denkmal verschwindet unter dem eindruck
des russischen angriffskriegs in der
ukraine hatte die regierung per gesetz
entschieden glorifizierenden sowjet
objekte müssen in ganz lettland
verschwinden wir lieben unser land unser
wundervolles großartiges lettland mit
eigenen symbolen und eigener geschichte
weg mit erinnerungen an die verhasste
sowjetische okkupation auch der
baltischen nachbarn estland entfernt
nach und nach sowjetische denkmäler in
der ersten mission grenzstadt zu
russland narva wurde unter anderem ein
umstrittenes ort panzer monument
demontiert in nawa leben vor allem
ethnische russen ein drittel davon
bedauert die entscheidung beim abbau
hatte es proteste gegeben aber ohne die
befürchteten zwischenfälle
es gab auch die idee ein spezielles
schild anzubringen so dass das denkmal
nicht mit besatzung verbunden ist navas
behörden haben dafür gekämpft aber
leider hat das nicht funktioniert
stattdessen wurde der sowjetische panzer
denkmal ins estnische kriegsmuseum bei
tallinn gebracht
das ist gut es steht für putins regime
und musste entfernt werden
rund ein viertel der estnischen
bevölkerung sind ethnische russen ihre
teilweise nähe zu putin ist der
regierung ein dorn im auge
deshalb müssen wir diese monumente die
als waffe im informationskrieg dienen
mit dringlichkeit entfernen für den
innenpolitischen frieden es sind vor
allem die nicht russisch stämmigen
balten die die in stein gemeißelte
vergangenheit nicht mehr im alltag vor
augen haben wollen
unruhige zeiten auf unserem kontinent um
umbrüche anderer art geht es gleich in
der 37° -reportage tanz auf dem seil
über zirkuskinder zwischen tradition und
moderne
und zwischen heute und morgen wenn man
so will meldet sich wohl schließen noch
mal mit dem heute-journal update nämlich
um mitternacht
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend aktuell reicht eine
hochdruckbrücke von skandinavien bis in
den atlantik und so kann sich die warme
luft die von diesem tief hier angezapft
wird bei uns richtig gut erwerben und
zwar verbreitet auf über 30 grad wir
meteorologen nennen so etwas einen
hitzetag frankfurt am main westend hat
davon in diesem august schon 16 gehabt
und stellt damit den rekord aus dem jahr
2018 ein bassum in niedersachsen gab da
gab es in diesem august schon zehn
hitzetage der rekord lag im jahr 2020
bei acht im osten im norden und dem
süden des landes da fehlt allerdings
teilweise noch fehlen noch einige
hitzetage bis zum rekord wir schauen
jetzt in die nacht haben wir noch einige
wolken von der oder über das erzgebirge
in den südosten bayerns die schauer
lassen nach in der feuchten luft bildet
sich nebel sonst ist es meist gering
bewölkt die temperaturen sinken auf 18
grad an der nordsee und 8 grad am
alpenrand
morgen wird es in der westhälfte dann
wieder sehr heiß mit temperaturen
zwischen 27 und 34 grad richtung
moseltal der osthälfte ist es angenehmer
mit 24 bis 29 grad dazu gibt es hier nun
auch einige wolken vereinzelt gibt es da
aber auch nur schauer an der grenze zu
polen sonst fällt wieder kein tropfen
regen nachmittags werden im westen die
wolken dann auch noch mal häufiger dazu
gibt es am donnerstag in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen nachmittags auch mal ein
einzelnes gewitter es bleibt aber sehr
heiß im westen mit viel sonne am freitag
da stellt sich die wetterlage um es wird
kühler und es gibt schauer und gewitter